[Music]
I'm just gonna start at the beginning
Richard welcome to the show and thanks
for coming to Austin
Tim I'm honored to be here it is very
much my pleasure and I was mentioning
this before we start recording I have
had you at the top of my list for people
I want to spend time with because I find
just about everything about you
fascinating have wanted ask so many
questions and I thought we would start
maybe in a place that that would be
unexpected for people listening I'm not
going to start way at the beginning in
childhood we'll probably get there but
let's start with the Magic Castle what
what is the Magic Castle the Magic
Castle is to magic with the Grand Ole
Opry is to country-western music it's
the premium place for magicians to
perform or around the world and they
have what is the equivalent of the Oscar
at the Academy of magical arts awards
AMA awards and but we uh it's a twenty
seven thousand square foot Victorian
mansion built 1907 and there's you go in
strictly for adults 21 or over must have
ID back to the old days you have to have
coat and tie you cannot over dress if
you're underdressed they don't let you
they don't like what you just they don't
let you in and in this by invitation
only but it's just a very very fun venue
in place to perform
I just got returned from perform at the
castle night before last
I just forgot that you've one of the
busiest schedules I've ever heard of and
I've met some very very driven busy
people but the Magic Castle has been
this vision in my head or it was I
should say for many years and I had the
opportunity to go there for the first
time just last year with with a member
and it just blew my mind to see the
variety of skill and the level of skill
in the various rooms because there are
these these different rooms for
different perform performers and
different types of performances
do you speak to and I I hope I'm getting
this name right dai vernon oh yes you
got it right so who is Diver Ninh and
how did you first meet
well dive Vernon first of all was born
in 1894 he lived to be over 98 years old
my wife my beautiful wife Kim and I
threw him his 90th birthday party two
months before he passed away and he was
known as the man who fooled Houdini and
that took place a hundred years ago this
year Wow hundred years ago and Budin had
a boat that he could he solved the same
trick three times he could figure it out
Vernon did did it for him five times he
couldn't figure it out and so he was
known as the man who fooled Houdini and
for over a half a century he was the
best in the world with a deck of cards
and there's different types of magic
there's the big what we call furniture
movers the big illusionists and most of
those things those that type of show is
really money more than Talent you just
have to pay two hundred thousand dollars
to buy this big illusion it turns a cat
into a person you know inside of a cage
or whatever and then there's the parlor
magician whether the link rings and make
eggs come out of their mouths or
whatever something along those lines
were a smaller audience but that's
called parlor magic
then there's the close-up magician who
will do stuff right in front of your
eyes like no make coins jump from one
hand to the other and or they'll do card
tricks but the most difficult of all
forms of sleight of hand is the work for
the card table the gambling work and
that work is the most closely guarded
information of all sleight of hand
nowadays with the internet just about
everything is exposed and Vernon wanting
to know about Morgan about more about
the moves of the gamblers first read a
book a night you've written in 1902
called expert at the card table by SW
herb days and nobody's knows who earn
days was and at that time the magicians
in the nineteen teens and 20s they oh we
don't care about that but that stuff's
too hard to learn and Vernon had it
mastered by time he was like twelve
years old and and so he spent his life
hunting down hustlers he was the first
one that found Alan Kennedy a 1930-31
who supposedly could deal cards from the
middle of the deck which no one thought
that was possible and so that and that
information was the most closely guarded
pieces of sleight of hand that you can
get ahold of if she'd get ahold of it he
had passes on just special people like
Charlie Miller and a few others and he I
met him in 1975 I argue I'll tell you a
quick backstory
yeah it doesn't have to be quick okay
please go ahead I was working with a guy
named Bob Yorkist whitey rkts he was
just at my show on Sunday he's gonna
turn 87 next month he's been in stunts
he's been stunt business for 73 years
his first movie was in 1947 with
Elizabeth Taylor and he's doubled
everybody Under the Sun literally
thousands of stunts in on television
thousands of stunts in film I could move
the earth telling infernal or earthquake
he died seven times in earthquake there
now died of multiple times in towering
frontal and on and on he was on the move
recently with Tom Hanks on angels and
demons he was the minister that was
being burned alive and they forgot to
turn the fan on to blow him out and Tom
Hanks says well Lee she didn't have to
act because he was an actor he was free
but anyway but anyway so I was working
with him we were training that it was a
show called circus of the stars we
trained celebrities do circus acts and I
was from better or worse I'll just call
her Mike got his gopher and but I lived
with him and he's a dear dear dear
friend for a husband 50 almost 50 years
and and so we were trading for the
circuses of stars and a Linda Carter
show called Wonder Woman and I died
Verne and heard I could do some very
difficult moves with the cards I just
turned 21 and I found I was gonna meet
him at the Magic Castle I found out the
night before I had to have a suit to get
into the castle at that time I couldn't
afford a suit I didn't have a suit and
so I thought okay I had my gambling
money always had a yoicks
at that time stacks of 20s which was a
lot of money for me and that's why it
went to the Northridge shopping center
set my deck of cards on a coat rack
started thumbing through coats your
sales guy comes up to me and says I'll
set your high card for that goat I
thought to myself this is my luck you
did I said no no I'm just kidding
nice to tell you what I took out two
twos and a queen as it come over to your
desk here I've moved him I said if you
tell me where that cleaners I'll pay
double for the coat I break down if you
get it wrong you give it to me for free
and he goes really I said really well I
threw those cars and darn if he doesn't
miss it I should tell you what
I bet the Cody gets a pair of pants if
you can't go back he goes okay
lost again I said take coat pants
against a shirt and tie he's okay but
it's the last one and he lost again so I
walked out of there dip but the brand
new suit didn't pay a dime and if I
would have known he was gonna go for it
I wouldn't have picked off the cheapest
coat the place was a pretend corduroy
piece of crap
that I still have today because it's how
I first met Vernon and so I still have
the silver there but anyway so I get to
the castle and and he Vernon there was
two guys in the room dai vernon and this
was in the library which is separate
closed off to the public and in another
guy named Tony Giorgio who's best known
as the actor in the movie Godfather he
prayed blade Runa to tag Leah which was
video called Ionians toughest head
spread and there's a scene in the movie
where a guy takes a knife and stabs his
hand in the bar yeah the guy with that
knife that was Tony Jordans Tony and he
was a bust out man back in the 40s and
50s
what is bust out man the bus stop man is
somebody who a casino will have on hand
oh hey that's Tim Ferriss he's got some
money okay Tony
take him out fast so bust out man means
that are gonna take you down they're
gonna take you down quick get that one
from you or if it turns out that that
Tim Ferriss he was just too lucky okay
Joe you're out here Tony you're in get
that money back and getting back means
bust you out fast I'm using car
technique uses sleight of hand using car
techniques exactly the agam removes
whatever it whatever his artifice was
Fabia's that shapes a peak with a second
deal and then one more time a peak that
was he would peak the top card and we
know it's top card is and then he would
deal the card under the top card so you
can see that card on top what's that
card that's final hearts okay and as as
he would yield to the other players see
that's hard it's not moving
it's for the for those who can't see
what we're doing I'm dealing the cards
in slow motion and the top card is not
moving as the second card comes out but
it looks as though it's the top of my
cake like here's even with one hand no
and it works when the cards face down I
turn it face down now you're watching
and you can't tell that you've been
swindle he would take him down and so
then it became an actor in their 60s and
anyway so at the table was diverting and
Tony Giorgio and Giorgio was you know he
was about six foot four mean nasty mafia
hitman I play I always used to say he
never had to act he just played himself
mean nasty mafia hitman and because we
had battles for all together 38 years
but we battle each other for 20 years
and at first I was no threat today I'm
showing Vernon my moves and he goes
Vernie goes well now that's alright but
but I don't care how fine you breathe
when you're moving your hand like that
it's unnatural
it's a tips you often every time I did
anything giorgio chip has seen from the
other table not involved in our little
private yet yeah they would yell we'll
get the money we'll get the money and
then I show something we'll get the
money we'll get the money what is it
well we'll get them on it yet the man
you will not get the money but it was
won't get the money which is in other
words it's not good enough for the card
table and so that's just that is the
sleight of hands smack talk that is yes
that is back dog that if the money that
is like your mama type of line eggs at
the card table yeah exactly
won't get the money here you get a
double banger you shot twice and and so
but Vernon then I showed him the move I
just showed you and that technique he
thought that was kind of clean it wasn't
more natural and so I remember Lee said
and I went home and that practice
he said I don't care how much you move
your hand no matter how fine that brief
is it's unnatural action so naturalness
that's why I've learned from burden that
Vernon naturalness you have to be
natural in your execution and and so I
practiced it the next time he saw me
goes down that's better that's better
and they took it and he took a liking to
me because he would see that I would put
in I practice at that time and this is I
and it's not an exaggeration even though
I almost wish it was because I I would
practice it average of 14 hours a day
that was my average time practicing but
sometimes it might be only 10 hours
because I spent extra time in the gym
because I was training for some kind of
a fight or in other days I got up at
6:00 in the morning went to bed at 3:00
and I might have may have practiced 20
hours that day but my average practice
time was 20 it was 14 hours and that was
sustained for 26 years seven day seven
days a week and Vernon saw this
obsession in me and so he took me on as
a well a student protege and to cut to
the chase I became the recipient of
essentially worth of his most guarded
card-table artifice that techniques that
he traveled the world I find on these
hustlers and learning their moves and
and he and I still have things today
that only he and I know and I've created
things today that only he and I know and
he's not telling anybody I think it was
a bad but that Benjamin Franklin said
three people could have a secret but you
have to kill two of them so if if we
talk about you or practice because your
your practice and work ethic it struck
me when I first saw dealt it struck me
as I've done homework and preparation
for this meeting
what makes good practice because there
are people who practice a lot they put
in a lot of hours but their skills don't
improve or improve much so what what
makes good practice for you very very
very good question - first of all I say
practice does not make perfect
so they say practice makes perfect no
practice does not make perfect perfect
practice makes perfect
right you can practice something wrong
when you're done it's perfectly wrong
and I see it in my industry all the time
they'll practice a second deal in some
awkward fashion where are the most
common one is a strike second I'll give
a visual clue
picture the card is turned face up on
the deck
they'll though hold first of all usually
they hold the deck in real tight what's
called a mechanic's grip a real deep
grip and I'll lighten up the grip a
little bit and then when they go to take
the card they'll bypass the card they've
taken is so they can just hit the second
card and deal it out and and that this
tip this is the standard second do that
you'll see people do it has all kinds of
tell and has a lot of tone first of all
you're pushing the top card over to
receive it with the other hand so why is
the right thumb bypassing that left them
in this because so they as exposure of
the top of the deck where that second
card is to get a hold of it that is a
totally unnatural action but you'll see
it all the time and then then and that
you don't have a dead deck when
efference students and who became a P
reference was a guy named tar Charlie
Miller who had the privilege of spending
time with and they grew up all through
the thirties forties 50 60 70 80 80 's
and Miller talks about a dead deck when
you're dealing the top card everything
below it there's no movement and so if
there's movement being made when you're
taking the separate card out and the top
card is going back you don't have a dead
deck you have movement of two different
movements there's second card coming out
the top card going back now watch my
second deal there's the there's no I'm
not crossing the thumbs at all and my
left thumb is there's no leaking of the
car and right at the other other corner
and I'm not going anywhere near the top
of the deck and this that particular
second DUI I have practiced I've done in
front of a live audience about five
million times and in practice I've done
it over a hundred million times that one
move and I I proclaimed as I say that
it's probably
most difficult move and all of sleight
of hand because there's only two three
other people that are getting it down
and one guy's been working on it after
he watched my videos for thirty years
now and uh but it just takes a long time
but anybody get off off a track practice
does not make perfect perfect practice
makes perfect
same thing with in the martial arts you
know you saw a sidekick your other
people dose will pick kick up as they go
you lift it and you shoot it in my cut I
come like a blade like as you practice
it wrong you said they're practicing
blow and you're done it's it's not wrong
it's perfectly wrong yeah okay and then
and then there's another thing I I like
to say
[Music]
discipline breeds discipline they say
how do you put in time and when I'm
telling people when they want to train
or something I say the more you do
something the more you can do have a
discipline breeds discipline you do
something and then the more you're able
to do it and the better you do it and so
and then they say well I just can't run
a marathon
I said don't run a marathon right now I
want you to just walk down the distance
of two houses and walk back make it so
easy
you can't talk yourself online the next
day walk the distance of three houses
come back then the next day jog down the
distance and come back and then
eventually your body starts adapting to
the habit and those endorphins start
getting released and then after a
certain period of time it's like will
you get back in the house does it have
to be a marathon you know a
sub-discipline breeds this one I love
the perfect practice makes perfect so
let's talk about your physical practice
the training and I have so many notes
here in front of me
it's an embarrassment of riches as as I
have written down here CBS producer
David Rubin Turner's life story is too
incredible for fiction and there's
there's a lot to that statement we'll
get back to you mentioned the stunt work
you've flown on a trapeze tightrope
walks you have iPhones yeah high falls
you've done it I've you've done an
incredible amount of physical
cultivation and I have have a line here
so on March 5th of this year you will
have not missed a workout in 49 years
true all right
why is training important to you why
would you go to the trouble as I have
down here in the 70s there were no gyms
when you were on tour so you traveled
with a wooden briefcase with a hundred
and twenty pounds of weights inside
sounds like a workout in and of itself
why is it so important to you um well
part of it is when I was growing up I
was always the second smallest or second
smallest in my class and I would get
beat up or I'd get pushed around and
then we watched and then we haven't
really got off on this point yet yeah at
nine years old I started losing my sight
all right my sister Lori who I called my
genius sister because he's brilliant and
I we both got scarlet fever I was nine
1963 she was five and that caused with
for me within a matter of moments I'm
fourth grade watching that's chalkboard
and all of a sudden it just went blurred
it was like someone takes the chart the
chalkboard smeared the chalk it was that
something it was that set in the same
way with my sister one minute in this
she went from from full sight to legally
blind and I sell now I'm we were forced
in second third and fourth grade to
watch would be called Lord of the Flies
and an ice to this day don't know why
they made kids watch a horrifying movie
like that and what it was about was a
group of kids stranded on an island at
the Bupa boys they were ball-like
between probably eight to twelve years
old somewhere in that age frame and
there was one boy called piggy and he
was a chubby boy and he had to wear
glasses and he had asthma
and they found out that they can use his
glasses to make a fire and because he
was chubby
they called him piggy and so he was
picked around and he had asthma and then
and when at ten years old I found out
that I had asthma and I'm just
definitely sick because we were very
poor our house literally was a structure
sat on a ditch about a six foot a foot
ditch and my dad poured concrete down in
that ditch to make my bedroom and during
the winter I my bed would have four or
five six inches of water under it which
means molds and I was definitely
allergic to bowls and I would just get
extremely ill and so I was now I'm blind
had asthma and I was skinny he would
chubby pig he was blind asthma and he
was chubby and so I thought I don't want
to be a picky I don't wanna be a coward
and I was afraid I was gonna be a coward
because I was afraid and I was afraid of
getting beat up and I was afraid when
I'm walking down the street a guy named
Leland you know picks a fight with me
and and and I get hurt Doug Ferguson
beat me up and others anyway so I I
didn't want that and then there was
another show that affected my what kind
of caused me to go are off the charts
the other direction was called lost in
space and there was a little boy on
there Billy Mumy
play Will Robinson and there was the man
on the show dr. Smith who was the man
the coward hiding behind a rock while
this goofy looking monster made out of
paper mache would come walking up and
Billy mama mummy would save the day that
little kid and I thought he's brave and
I was afraid of turned out like dr.
Smith and then that and then the third
thing was Tarzan movies they just see
them walk across a tree go a spanning
two cliffs that maybe a hundred feet
down a thousand feet down and they know
there was always the guy that turn
around save whatever you do don't look
down and then there were the next guy
would be the coward would look down and
go screaming to his death and I was
afraid I'd be that coward that would
look down and and and panic and fall
down so I started just taking things to
the outer limits as far as
pushing myself and and growing up that I
had three three movies on the other side
that affected me one was Ben Hur
starring Charlton house
Charlton Heston there's a scene in the
movie where he's pulling the oars with
his big bulging biceps and that image is
strength what you know made me want to
be strong I want to be strong I wanna I
want to be strong like him and another
one was the Green Hornet starring Bruce
Lee as as Kato
you know and you know and I I want to
take like Kato and and then for the
third one was was the one that really
probably set my life on fire was James
Garner in maverick he was the cool slick
gambler and I want to be a card shark
so those are the three things but that's
really what started me off on taking
things to the extreme whatever someone
else did whatever they benched I was
going to bench more whatever their split
was I got to write to do a 200 degree
split in fact I do
there was even video out there I'm
stretched across three chairs and I'll
touch my head to the floor
and so anyway I wish I just had this
thing of whatever someone else did I had
to top it not that I was able to top
everybody which I was not but I top
people in the top 1% and I've trained
with some very world-class athletes you
know and I either trained them or
trained with them and and and people
have a hard time you Frank keeping up
well I mean you're you're still an
extremely fit guy you told me before we
started recording that you worked out of
five this morning yeah whether they
accept it and you understand this sure
Nathalie it yourself you know that's
that's another great thing I I do cuz it
wakes me up it gets it gets the
adrenaline going the endorphins shooting
and and because I had I chose all week
last week every day and and I flew in
last night at 9:00 a at 9:00 p.m. and
I've thought okay I need to be on my on
my best game
I'm meeting Tim Ferriss and we're gonna
be talking for two hours and I have been
my voice was already worn from all the
shows I've done and that what's the best
late first person says best relaxed get
rate uh uh I was in the gym and then all
of a sudden I'm started at five and I
would it's oh my goodness after seven
I've been in here for two hours and 11
minutes my rides gonna be here in 49
minutes - to the down to fish tacos that
my wife made if she makes the best fish
tacos anywhere on the planet my life Kim
and I down those things and then shower
and here we are and here we are and as
you mentioned we hadn't covered and
hadn't talked about cited or the the
other CBS the and is it at Albany
Syndrome child Vinay syndrome that's a
French English is Charles bonnet
syndrome especially in Texas and I did
and I and I didn't bring it up earlier
very deliberately because I want people
to understand that you're incredibly
deft technical mastery of what you do
stands on its own head-to-head against
any one period full stop so I wanted to
make sure she ate that yeah it's true
and that's certainly been recognized by
many people and I so I didn't want to I
certainly want to chat about these the
Charles Burnett syndrome but I didn't
want to lead with it but but since since
it came up and and we chatted very
briefly about this before we started
recording could you please talk to me
about the red and blue spectrum because
because I've heard you or I've and I've
read you say
that you you can see things where you
see things that other people don't see
and I'd love to just know what your sort
of experience of reality is like my
world that I live in your world
yeah first let me explain what CBS
Chawan a syndrome is first documented
1760 by Charles Burnett John Burnett and
it's a very rare condition and dr.
Oliver Sacks he's a best-selling often
I'm sure amazing author yes I'm sure
you've met yes two books one called
hallucinations the other one called the
mind's eye where he goes into specifics
on CBS and he's probably documented more
cases than anybody and up till 1990
there was only six documented cases and
then he's now in six ups nineteen ninety
nine ninety haha and then he's
documented a few others and I'm Paul I'm
the most extreme case on the planet most
people what it first of all let's kind
of give you a picture view of what CBS
is Chobani and that's where you see a
person that's blind and should see
nothing will see sporadic colors or
splatters or pieces of images or or just
some visual things almost like
hallucinations right and there's
sporadic in my case I'm it's 100% 24/7
and it's not just just part of my vision
I see a one hundred and sixty degree
kaleidoscope of beautiful vivid colors
pattern shapes every subconscious image
you can imagine and I don't see them in
the back of the brain like when you
dream in or imagining I look at them I
see it in front of me
I see them in external space just like
you're seeing me in external space like
an object there's something I'm looking
at it right now I'm in the blue spectrum
and to explain the difference between
blue and red I have a neuroscientist
that was doing some interviewing me for
some projects and stuff and he said the
red spectrum which is more geometric
shapes it's everything is first of all
there's a grid it's usually a grid like
layers of bricks and they're always
perfectly aligned
and there's a perfect rectangle bricks
later just like a brick missiles in the
red or in this the red this is the red
okay and then there's us always maroon
which is my favorite color one of my
favorite color the red spectrum so the
brick what would be the the gray mortar
is actually maroon and then the red
bricks and in those bricks are all every
geometric shape circles squares
triangles stars just every geometric
shape you can imagine and in those
shapes will be any every subconscious
image that's floating around in my net
in my brain okay that's the respect to
me said that's the I remember that's the
lower part of the brain and um and then
the blue spectrum which is I call it the
right brain you know their analytical
the other is the blue spectrum which is
very artistic there's no R and it's not
as as totally random if you picture I
call it like breaststroke breaststroke I
like this too yeah oh but there's only
two breasts that I'm allowed to stroke
they belong to KITT okay and I don't
want any slaps um you know okay this is
so good brush strokes is right you see
we're buying my mind is right now
I just got in a week from wait a week
for a way from my beautiful wife okay so
brass I did you get brush I'm taking
Freddie ins slips off all week
and they're more frightening the better
it is so them in the blue you of these
brush strokes rush Stokes and then in
the royal blue - blue - turquoise blue -
sky-blue - emerald green - lime green
all the way down that that spectrum and
they're just random strokes and and then
floating around is like I said every
subconscious image you can imagine and
just pick yourself underwater in a pool
with the light coming in and the light
spectrum breaking down on like a prism
rent break some lights maybe so all
these colors just floating around is all
the images are two-dimensional but
they're layered three dimensionally if
you can picture that so I have hands of
glass yes it just back and forth your
depth
forward and and the thing about it is
I can take any particular image um and I
probably I'm I'm oh I won't get slapped
but she Michael I can like I take a
picture of image of my beautiful wife in
her bikini mhm and I can you take it
zoom it in rotate it you know or or
where I use it most is if I create a
designing them like I don't design about
my own homes
mhm and or I like it patio Jack and my
wife Kim I tell you I'm sitting in my
chair
and I'm watching in full 3-dimension
like virtual reality I basically live in
virtual reality and so my whole my my
spectrum is my own computer so I wanted
to design a Dell and I built this three
level deck and I would say okay I need
four by twelves posts now for my tone
across there and then enough to buy
sections I'll anchor in there and you'll
watch me we were looking back and forth
engineering this giant projects with a
giant project with a thousand cuts it
was three levels stairway hanging swings
built in flower flower beds and without
a single piece of paper then I'd tell my
dad okay
he was my cutter I said this board has
to be 192 and a quarter inches and and I
and my dad is a genius my dad was a
worked well he was one of my my role
models but but I can't tell him or my
wife what I'm going to do because I
can't explain a thousand cuts and what
I'm doing is all in here and so then we
would start putting it together and then
here watch this whole thing from the
other girls now I understand what you
say what you were talking about doing so
that's one of the ways that I'll use it
and probably the thing I use it all
mostly is like how I remember phone
number I can write the number down in
the air
I'll see you floating in the air just
like you'd see it on a computer screen
my mind takes a picture of it and I have
what's called an eidetic memory and then
I just files away I bring it back out or
would I practice it with cards I will
and I do this every time I'm at a
restaurant or when I'm people and I I'll
have the table and I'm watching the move
and I'm analyzing something I'm doing
and I'll see it and my mind will jet
create the image and it's not flesh like
you have it's more of a conglomeration
of all kinds of geometric shapes or
images to create the image of an arm
right the the image of the cards so it's
not flesh and blood color in the same
way you would see it but I'd well see
the thing the the image of the
constructed within my mind what I'm
looking at and then I'll analyze it now
then I'll be in the and I'll see
everything going on yeah there's a solid
object between me and what I'm looking
at all right but yet here's the
interesting thing if I turn like this
can't do it if you turn your hand if I
turn my head I have to be looking at the
object like my medicine cabinets an
example I have a friend who's a writer
he thought this was interesting my
medicine count on one where is that
Campbell for nique okay and now you see
everything in my medicine cabinet going
down ah there it is
and I'm seeing everything yet the doors
closed well okay but now if I turn late
this way I have to see it my mind I
can't see it in front of me oh wow kind
of interest that's fascinating and in
there but anyway so I I considered a
real blessing that I have have this
strange condition and because I use it
all the time and uh like I said I
consider myself very very blessed and
and within seconds you are I can shake
someone's hand and I usually I can tell
their height weight characteristics
about them and my mind will create an
image what I think they look like in my
mind sometime they totally all left
field but you know creators of my own
impression of the Hammerson and then
when they're talking I will see some
strange looking conglomeration mouth
moving even though it's not less a
flesh-colored but it flesh looking or
human looking but it samples the best
representation of a movement in motion
well if you think about it also for
those people who are sighted I mean what
they are perceiving they consider
reality
but it's it's they have their own lens
you have your own lens and it's it's
there they're both representations in a
way if that makes sense
and I wanted to ask a few follow-up
questions with the the a Didache memory
the photographic memory is that's
something that you had partially or
fully before losing your sight or is it
something that was developed over time a
bit of both it was something I had
before him I remember when I was five
years old in kindergarten and we were
finger-painting class mm-hm
and I had a picture of a National
Geographic image that I saw of a
seascape and so all these other kids are
just doing the finger painting their
nose and their ears and their hair and
their table and I come up with this
seascape a night into this to this day
was 60 years later over 60 years later I
still see the exact thing that I created
sixty years later and it was your start
off with the the the ground and then I
had seaweed I'm sorry I touched your
deck forgive me okay seaweed growing up
and there would be a nurse's corner I
had a jellyfish with the things coming
down and a shark in the middle and just
different things that I that I
replicated from an image I saw in a
National Geographic look and and so from
from the ages five six seven eight I was
the best artist in the school and I
could like beside see a picture and I
could pretty much replicate it and and
then the problem and then were nice you
know nine and I had scarlet fever then I
started losing that ability being wrong
I must have been really difficult I
would imagine I mean how that was very
difficult and that was probably where
some rebellion took place I was shipped
off to a special school where they had
what it was called a v-8 room back then
visually handicapped and now you say
visually impaired you know politically
much more polite then visually
handicapped and I hated the word
handicapped
and that despise the word blind when I
was you know had to go to the school and
my sister Lori she only went there one
year she got she rebelled so much she
said put me back on a regular school she
refused to continue to go but my vision
was worse than hers at the time and so I
she was able to get away with it I was
not and so in the school the best artist
was a code name Sharon Coleman and she
was the best artist where I was always
the best artist here nor angka in first
second third fourth grade now I've said
nobody knows who I am nobody cares on
Sharon she's the one that does the best
artwork and and so there was a guy in VH
Department there was about a dozen of us
that and we'd go to it was a regular
school but they had a VH Department Viet
visually handicapped department and one
of the guys in the v8 room was guy named
Reuben corral who because he was from
Mexico was like twice my size and it was
2 to 3 years older than I was but he
were in the same grade because he didn't
have the opportunity to go to special
school and he would just scribble he
couldn't draw it also and he got deadly
good so he got attention for just doing
crap and so I started doing crap I
started showing my skills with the best
I could I started I just started going
the other direction and just scribbling
although I did do one three-dimensional
project that dr. Sam Kumbi was a teacher
I did a sculpture and I still have it in
my office you can still see it today of
of a Buddha monk and a bald head in and
anyway in the end it was all what would
the word it was all properly
proportioned and I got a in that for
that lunging and that's why the few
things that I do I still have from that
but that was a three-dimensional thing
why didn't you keep that because I got
it because it was actually I think you
should know does it I did a good job but
there's that's a also an astute question
on your end
because I there was other pieces I did
and in high school I did a collage and
and I I was just rushing through my art
class because I could do stuff and if
you got seven and a half points you got
it a-and I could have my art projects
done within up the first month of the
semester and I already got my so I did I
could mess around after that and I did
this one project I don't even know what
was to this day I don't know what was so
good about it but we had a teacher was
mr. sueños his assistant told members
name when he went to San Diego State
University
he took my art project and entered it
into a statewide college competition and
it got first place and he gave me the
ribbon the blue ribbon for first place
and they just put it on display in the
hallway if the high school you know
those little slides where the lock doors
lock Windows Nate and and then when I
said oh I can't get my our project block
and they went there notice it was gone
no breaking there was no glass broken so
we figured the student that claimed it
to be his that entered it obviously went
off with it but other projects after
that I started I would have to get my a
build my project and you know especially
the three-dimensional ones right it's
good at and then I prefer I purposely
sabotage them could you fire them in a
kiln yeah and and if you have something
that's air in it it is completely sealed
it blow up so I'd make my project get my
grade on it and then went out to go have
it fired I'd purposely put in either a
ball of clay with a hole in it right
that's it would have sealed air in it or
build something in it so when it was
fired it blow up
why didn't you know cuz I just I I was I
was angry that I lost I was little I was
losing my vision and losing my ability
to paint and draw on and so this was
just one of the ways I was being ornery
and just rebelling against my my loss so
I would love to ask you about and this
is fair from the very first moment that
I saw the documentary of
I've wanted to ask you about anger and
rage because one of my first thoughts
upon watching the documentary which was
very emotional for me to be honest was
that any woman who ever dates me should
have to watch this movie because it'll
give her a better understanding of how
consumed in a different for different
reasons but consumed I was by anger or
driven by it at the very least how did
you how did you relate to anger or what
purpose did it serve for you then and
and how do you relate to it now that's a
big questions yeah you can break it up
into any huge segments yeah at the time
I try to just describe how I dealt with
some of my anger and that was
self-destructive and I had gone into
other self-destructive behavior and I
leaves late 60s Begins 70s and so for
about three years drugs was a part of
that as an act of rebellion and and and
and purposely not trying to do my best
the only thing I did worked at that
worked out was cards and I would play
cards with people and I would take their
money and in wit my dug my dragon
partner named Doug Ferguson who died
from hepatitis from dirty needles and he
would have me he would have me play
cards against other drug dealers and to
cheat him or tricked him out of their
money and that's how we supported
ourselves and we well we made our money
to buy and sell and so that was kind of
I actually that was kind of a power the
only power that I had the rest of the
time I was laughed at and there would be
times where we would be doing something
drug and then when I'd come out of a
stupor a blur they'd be laughing at me
and and and they were they were at first
they were the only people that accepted
me because there I was this is the drug
the drug the drug crowd except they
don't we don't care if you can't say you
know come on over and there were just
the regular students were were more
discriminating towards some of us in the
VH rooms and then and so the drug people
they didn't care but then when it got
right down to it it was more of I was
more of a tool of of their of amusement
for them and and then event and then I I
met a guy and and and then we go on
another little tangent here yeah it was
a verse in the Bible said God created us
in His image and that always fascinated
me in His image
and so I thought okay I'm in the image
of God what did God take dirt and made a
person doctor God took dirt made eyeball
God did dirt in made a brain God took
dirt and made a bird and and I I
remember watching an episode of kung-fu
and they said who would teach me about
the universe the universe will teach you
and I thought well that's like saying
the wall would teach me but who built
the wall the wall who built the Statue
of Liberty there wasn't the Statute of
Liberty didn't build the Statue of
Liberty so then I start thinking what
what me and the image of God okay God
created the bird man took dirt and we
created a jet got to dirt made I we took
dirt made a camera there staring us all
over the place
Gajic dirt and made a brain we took dirt
and made a computer what's in the ship
and oh here's base and dirt just about
everything in this room and one fashion
or another came from dirt and so I
thought okay that means I can create and
so um I went another direction I got
heavily into the martial arts started in
nineteen March 5th 1971 and micron
instructor was a man named John Murphy
that positive for once are you so what
sit ated that 90-degree turn or that 180
was there a conversation or a particular
day more what catalyzed what catalyzed
that turn was I was with some friends
and they wanted to watch a movie called
Fantastic Voyage which was a movie about
shrinking down us us a ship a submarine
and then setting it into a by the guy's
body he'll go into his heart and to try
to fix it okay and they've said hey
fantastic voyages on let's get some
angel dust and watch the movie and then
they end
and so I I realize I gotta stop this and
there was something out there saying you
need to stop it or you can end up dead
like belly Macomb and I had a half a
dozen well that's a dozen friends who
have now od'd and were dead and and I
thought if I don't stop this I'm gonna
be next and I realized I need some help
anyway so I went to I went to these
people at this part Wales park and I
asked them if they had any ancient us
they said we have something better I
said with that they said a relation with
the creator of everything you see
I said you mind if I stayed on tell me
what you know and they're the ones that
told me that we're not here by accident
we're here by design and if there is a
creator and so it was that that one word
that I said I was going to change my
directions around and and then you
mentioned the martial arts and Murphy
that was that that was what that was I'm
a very I could every moment of my life
is like a video I can watch in pin and
on every any exact image or moment that
was a February 13 71 you know three
weeks later you know March 5th my
brother who was seven years younger than
me he's nine and he was taking karate
and I wanted to take party because I was
tired of it yeah I'll get beat up I'll
get off a little tangent I entered
another art competition when I was 11
and I was I had to have my nose like two
inches from the canvas as I painted
these three bosses they
with proper shadow lights coming in you
got first place these two boys didn't
like that there's blind kids got first
place and they called me mr. medulla
there was a cartoon out at that time I
was writing Jim Backus called mr. Magoo
Lucy's kind of this goofy sighted person
that just went through life jolly just
missing trains and planes trains and
automobiles and that was me
and so they would say that said the bird
in front of my face is a Heimlich ooh
how many fingers am i holding up
and we're lastest fact just try his
friend picked a wallet on my back pocket
then dangled in front of my face said he
Magoo got any money when I grabbed for
my wallet he didn't throw it over my
head to his friend behind me and a cool
game of keep-away and they kept every
time I turn around grabbed it let's just
keep going back and forth over my head
and then finally when I'm started
literally slapping me across the cheeks
with my own lawn Wallace ain't got any
money my blind boy and the other kid
jumped on my back drove me to the ground
kicked me in the ribs and they ran off
laughing saying thanks for the hot dog
Magoo cuz I had $3 in there for me $3
was I'm a that was all my entire life
savings card play and everything all
rolled up into three bucks and so I was
so upset about that and so that jumps
forward to the martial arts is that
where were ya and anyway sweat brother
was taken cut out they and so I wanted
to go down and they they gave him
warning well you know this guy can't see
in and Murphy he didn't care if you're
blind deaf or dumb he's enemy please let
my sensei sensei dumber he was a year
ahead of Chuck Norris he was a class of
Norris class started in 58 and he opened
up Murphy opened up his school in
Tijuana in 1960 and he was the first
white guy who was called like I'd
Caucasian he was Irish to get a black
belt in Japan yeah in this particular
system what a fact which is a kind of a
cross between Shotokan and Taekwondo or
you know it combines hands and feet
where one Shotokan six Shotokan versus
the number one style was really
basically mini hands
anyway he said we'll take him we'll take
him then first he told him don't hurt
him in the first and the girls I'd get
beat up by the girls I'd be get beat up
by the old ladies ladies that we would
know well who would be their driver you
old enough to be my mother and it was
all I could do to keep from ended up on
the ending up on the floor and so I
realized okay I gotta I gotta start
getting better this and at that time I
weighed 110 pounds and I got my four
five nine and Murphy still can't watch
you start takin you need to start
lifting weights because you gotta put
some meat on those bones
so I started punching pushing weights
and I went to gene Fisher's gym and
Fisher he held the world's record for
the curl at that time 1963 221 pounds
total 21 reported and 226 unrecorded and
and of course he was in the 200 pound
category and so at that time I weighed
130 130 pounds and got 230 pounds in a
130 pounds I could pull down to 20 and
he would have to pull me down lock me in
do my reps lifting back up I could I was
about 250 on the bench at that time at
130 pounds and and then Murphy would say
pushed me the point where I could do 500
push-ups in 12 minutes 9 seconds which
is my record but he is 500 push-ups made
15 minutes which was actually real world
class time the record of thinking I can
do 500 push-ups in 15 days you're just
listen to him say that tim is an athlete
tim is probably just as crazy as I am
Oh being modest right now I'm just
telling you because he doesn't want
speak for himself
listen to what I'm saying everybody Tim
I felt him out when we first got
together and I mean that in a nice way
okay check those forearms just forms
Popeye I know jealous Popeye you jealous
Olive Oyl he's over here okay so 500
push-ups thing you were saying that
during the 20 that I slipped here
earlier before the reported reference in
time was 9.19 hundred hours so as well
I was world class time you know 15 in in
one quarter the time
one fourth in Florida at Joe's and then
and that's when I travel around with
that briefcase with 120 pounds 20 pounds
in dumbbells it would be broken apart
put together on the road do my exercises
and so on anyway so Lynn Murphy says you
would pay me more weight and so he said
tell one's taking vitamins vitamins
every day so I start eating vitamins he
said protein powders so I've found for
the past 50 years almost 49 years every
morning I'd throw everything onto the
side throw my vitamin tablets in the
blend and blend them up with with the
protein powder and then I came up with
the best drink for if you wanna you have
two choices
burn up or work out like a madman and I
call it liquid hell alright and what it
is you take water as your base yeah and
that put in shifts brewers yeast which
really is tasty tastes bad yeah I put it
half a banana for potassium and three to
four to six jalapeno peppers blend it up
and it yeah you got two choices you
either worked out or you just sweats
just start pouring out your head and my
my workout partner Jim Bowers who you
probably saw in delt he was the one that
was talking about riding on the back of
my motorcycle tell me where to go and he
said when he first started carotid
college I said okay you have to have
some liquid hell and either the first
time he did it threw up in the sink and
then I said you're not wasting that Lake
Liddell you drank the rest of that and
so he got it down in it and he couldn't
go through a final without traveling is
liquid hell because it stimulated his
brain in the spine
anyway so but it's not for sissies I'll
just say that anyway so that's what I
would drink to to just boost the the
energy level and anyway so I finally put
on some weight and then I remember 1980
is when I broke
at 160 got 160 pounds and then I kept
pressing and I got up to I I worked out
with a Joe Doug no Lee who was mr.
universe at his place
and he had I got up to 340 on the bench
that's why I topped out at and I weighed
in at 168 and and today when I got my
first black belt my first degree black
belt and Murphy wanted the hardest test
and it was considered the hardest test
at the time you had to fight a tan round
out with a fresh fighter each round ten
three-minute rounds and he didn't care
about he didn't want to deal with
lawsuits so most of the testing and
training took place across the border of
San Diego and t1 so that's where is
school yet school in the States and
another main question for you is it true
that you were offered an honorary black
belt yes because I and you did not
accept no but you get my first belt I
had to fight one round three minutes and
plus all the Connors nothing about
Connors because my eidetic memory I
could memorize them in one day right
yeah and in fact when I when I got my
fourth degree by blood ayah at a sixth
degree black belt Tata
that I learned in one day the guy who
went through it and then the next thing
he sees it on family goes I can't
believe you did it we just you just I
just showed that to you bla bla bla
globe just days before you know and for
those people who don't know kata is a
predetermined sequence of moves that you
perform alone exactly doing punches
kicks blocks counters in the yeah so
that it's like a martial arts dance
right so six degree black belt kata
would be like someone being shown a sort
of very complex and halftime performance
at the Super Bowl dance routine and then
being able to replicate it shortly
thereafter perfectly perfectly explained
exactly Tim and so I guess it caught us
and all that stuff down overnight
right right off the bat it was the
fighting because just let you understand
how I was seeing at the time because I
had some vision
at that time my teens and 20s my vision
was measured at 20 over 420 over 450
with no center vision because my macula
which is the center of the eye was gone
okay so there's no macula that's your
forward vision so if you just picture
yourself there's a hat in front of your
face wherever I turn my head there's a
hat blocking that part of vision okay
with me out of the corner of my eye was
24 450 so 2,200 is legally blocked 2050
is you have to have at least 2050 to
drive so out of the corner of my eye
that's where I would see the images or
shadows of my opponent and so I'd always
be looking at you like cockeyed I was
wondering about that because I noticed
that in the footage from the documentary
yeah Gannett's you're looking at your
peripheral vision yes because I had no
forward vision though and and that's how
I know what I'm looking at people at
that time now I have no vision at all
but at that time if I if I couldn't see
anything I knew I was looking right at
you which is anyway so um because my
first first belt yellow was one fight
green belt had five 2-minute rounds five
bouts five rounds two with a fresh fight
or two-minute rounds and on a scale of
one to ten I trained I practiced sights
and I thought okay I figure it's gonna
be a maybe a four five or six it turned
out to be a twenty it was beyond my
worst nightmare and it was August 2nd
1972 and it was over a hundred degrees
outside and our dojo was in Tijuana as I
said there was a solid block brick blah
submit block building no windows no air
conditioning even a fan wood floor
scratched up wood floor and whenever
they would have tests all the it was
like blood sports like fights and
so all the sadistic people would come
out to watch whenever they hear that the
good INGOs are gonna be coming up and
there's gonna be some fights and so John
Douglas was testing for his black belt
that day and I was testing for my green
belt I was the I was the I was a
pre-show before the big show
the war love that whatever is a I was
the warm-up act and so I get out there
thinking and and it was because we're
all crammed into these little thing that
humidity factor was in there huh and
then 90s yeah so before I even started
on porn I was gasps refreshed whose eyes
did my first a toccata group then I did
my defense I was already gasping and
then I start my first round and right
before we start at Murphy's the rule was
we would respect each other's head if
you don't hit me in their face I won't
hit you in the face
body's open target no limit okay the
groin shots everything the way we would
respect each other's needs
no knee shots everything else is open if
you hit me in the face then the face
becomes an open target and so Murphy
said now if these guys start hitting you
in the face
don't think about it just keep fighting
and at that time I thought what I
thought we were gonna mark our shots to
the face and within the first three
first few seconds of the first round
Bam Bam Bam three shot Bam Bam Bam right
in my face and I'm going oh my god yeah
yeah yeah I'm fine I was fighting for my
life because they didn't like us Green
goes down there
everything was just set in you know
discriminate against there had the black
clam or the black fighters back
federation and the mexican fighters and
their gringos right and I'm so I know
the first round I'm not just gasping for
air second round that this guy watched
the Bruce Lee will be a mentor the
dragon or knows before that Fist of Fury
where he does a step uphill who expends
around with another he'll cook i catched
the one I I blocked out boom only get
nailed with with the other one coming
around the other way and third round
this guy would like me so I kept getting
knees in the groin
fourth round the guys was even stands he
switched stances on me grab my front
hand went right by me and bam right in
my left eye caught on or uzuki or right
hand punch and pretty much knocked me
out at out now I've seen enough I'm just
seein stars and Murphy says wipe off the
but don't think about it keep fighting
and I'm just holding myself up against
the bathroom and I could be I couldn't
even kill my hands up by this point and
so then the fifth round was probably my
best round because I was really a
standing I was just a standing
I was virtually unconscious and then
they yelled Moroz mayor's wife yells
tempo which means time in Spanish and
the second she railed temple is what I
hit the ground so I got it by one second
and then I was so exhausted and have an
asthma attack I I had to I know I had to
stand up you had to battle out and as
soon as I thought I hit the ground again
now everybody wants to congratulate me
I'd stand up again we weren't allowed to
have water and so I crawled to the
bathroom and John died goes to tell the
story but Murphy's bar get mad at me for
telling it and when he came to he says
that's not the saint you're drinking out
of that's the toilet TJ TJ toilet and I
go I don't care I was so days and I got
gonorrhea oh yeah but anyway so that was
screamed out so then I've been brown
belt was ten two-minute rounds and Imagi
and then I of course on that one
I owe I trained my command all because I
wasn't gonna have that last experience
so I made that and then from brown to
black was such a jump it took me another
ten years before I was able to take on
the ten fighters and just to give you a
quick rundown of what my workout looked
like to prepare for it warm up with a
four-hour weight workout a four hour for
hour and I would start minimum weight
all the way up to maximum weight and I
do as men know I get to the maximum I do
weight lifters many times as I could
with a few seconds but many times it
good
then I'd slowly off just five pounds at
a time from 300 from 300 pounds 395
dives to 95 to 98 out to where I had
just the bar which is a 45 pound bar and
and then that and I do that with every
muscle group and then I would do 500
kicks on the heavy bag you know ten
roundhouse kicks with us say ten where
this what ten tend to a hundred that
yeah I do ten side kick with this leg 10
side kick with this like 10 sec another
110 bacterin cakes ten side whatever I
was type of cries I kick but you just
did five different cakes five hundred
times then my trainer he would have a
well it looks like a motorcycle seat was
a bag and
hold it and and with his hand and then I
would have to 100 kicks in three minutes
and so simulating the three rounds so
I've just Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam punch kick
punch shake mainly kicking is that that
is that exhausts your oxygen supply
faster than punching that's why in
kickboxing matches they're required to
throw a minimum of the six kicks rate
kicks and that's because after you start
getting tired you just wanna punch takes
a fraction a toss it does to take to
lift these big muscles up in the air and
so I do that and I take it first I'm
taking a ten second break to another
hundred and ten now it's a 20 second
break 100 I do a thousand I do it ten
times would be another thousand case
from there I would do a five-mile run
and I lived in San Diego and that was
here that big Hills there and I would
one of the hills is a mile and a half
down a mile and a half back up and when
I got to the top I was sprint the
distance of a house and then run the
distance print run spent and then I
would do ten quarter mile wind sprints
and then I throw up and then I'd go do
my show that you'll perform I'd perform
that night and then every other day I
would go rounds you know Murphy Douglas
would have me a yo-yo - five rounds you
know five rounds building up to it and
sometimes two on one because you don't
have time to to rest and that and but
that's that was and I sustained that
particular discipline for eight months
and Deborah said I over trained you know
went too long but my problem was asthma
cuz you know being an asthmatic you know
if I sometimes fear can trigger an
asthma attack that's what happened on
that green belt that I described yeah
and you can't fight if you can't breathe
and so I had to train my mind to not
become afraid you know fear can paralyze
you know we can be so worried about
doing the wrong thing that we do nothing
there's actually a English problem that
says a man is afraid to make a mistake
is unlikely to make anything in other
words totally worthless fire the bomb
fear of failure when left unchecked can
actually lead to the failure we fear
yeah and so I I just started like I said
putting myself in positions and
conditions to help my mind
overcome those effects and I did things
I we just talked about the physical I
did mental things like hey eating live
cockroaches reliance hoppers the most
absurd things rotten fish gots a sat in
the Sun for a week - don't you saw the
right it chopped down on the eyeball of
the mahi-mahi and the thing is if you
don't have if you if you can't take it
you know your person would throw up and
some people that were watching it almost
throw up one time one of when I do the
guts they did throw up don't try this at
home don't try this at home
but is a closed track with a trained
professional it was just to train my
mind to be able to take whatever is
being dished out and if I controlled my
mind and body then I can make it and
that triggers another thought real quick
I'm gonna go back to the child Bonet
syndrome Charles bonnet and how that can
create strength one of the ways I use it
the most and that we haven't even best
is in training as what I can do
tremendous numbers of reps well I took
my fourth degree black belt test I was
in my late for I was 47 to 48 I lifted
two hundred twenty two thousand eight
hundred eighty eight pounds used in 3190
reps and the 24 year old 220 pound black
belt who trained alongside me could not
do 50 percent of the number of reps or
weight and that's because I don't get a
slack t'k acid buildup because I would
combine the mind with the body now you
see wait people do this those you know
they're trying to convince their body to
do it your follower I'm saying yeah when
you combine mind and body together
they're not doing that and what I would
do is when I get to the point of
exertion and I would then transfer I'd
use my V CB s I like had a bench press I
would see a cable or I'm the bench press
I'd see a cable it up across of it
across to poised on the other end it's
as guerrilla shape they were an Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Grill it together
pulling on that thing pulling that
weight up and I would focus on that
image
pulling the weight up and during that
I would no longer feel the stress as my
muscles continue to press and I have
exercised forever I have a mental
visually exercise I'll use for each
exercise like the quadricep extension
you know you're you're in exertion when
you're straightening your legs right
when so what I would see in front of me
is a big giant rubber band when the
brand has stretched down when the when
the weights are down and then it would
wouldn't it would the blubber band would
go up and it would just go wide and
that's when it's pulling the weight up
so I'd watch it and I would see it
pulling the way it up so what I'm doing
the exertion is when I'd feel at the
least or another image like when I'm
doing a hammer I got my on my back doing
a tricep I would see a hammer falling
okay and when the Hammers falling is the
least amount of effort right because
they haven't the way the hammer is going
down but when I'm like this so I'd see
the hammer falling and but yes that's
when the tricep is being engaged and I
taught my wife I when you had taught my
wife this and and within a month times
what she would do I say we'll look
herself in the bear your reflection and
when you get to exertion like exam I
like a bet military compress yeah if
there were point of exertion so yet you
want to do we'd always do sets of 52
reps when you get to a 48 with then
transfer that seeing that image of that
reflection pulling those weights up and
then and she got to the point where she
increased her muscular endurance 30% in
a month time and she was already in top
shape for self and if I can give you an
example of that if you if we were
standing if you want to stand up but I
would like I course now I'm saying it's
almost 66 so I don't know how I used to
have it as a demonstration that I would
do where I would bend the arm or the
person and that there's not others only
one person's arm I was not able to bend
into it doing this demonstration for 40
years and no one has ever been my arm
but if you want to stand up I can I
don't know if this is right so you could
I'm not gonna try to pin your on because
I might because I'm sort of I'll get on
this side of me all right let's see you
look at those muscles huh no I know it
usually I put myself up against the back
so I'm pinned
now I'm gonna have you put your hand on
I'm right here okay your other arm here
yeah okay got on the risk that one foot
rest and and your job just what you
already gonna do it's just been this
little wobbly right okay yeah okay go
ahead
well yeah isn't go come on come on it's
not gonna have I'm not and I'm not doing
any I'm not using any strength and I'll
leave my hand yeah
totally relax yeah I'll tell you how I
did it okay this is what's again it's
pretty mind and body together what I did
is I envisioned my arm is a fire hose
you know shooting out that fire holds a
thousand gallons of water a minute you
can't bend a fire hose I'm sorry
yeah right if you to think about a fire
hose when the players weather what water
water student you never been to fire
hose so I get that image in my mind I'm
just shooting that fire hose and and
I've never had anyone ever been my arm
and yet the without that until I'd show
them they kids they learn how to do that
then that kept in their arm but before
they were that's just kind of a little
side sight note but how I've used by CBS
to create a lot of strength and I also
used it in my training with the cards
without training when I went to analyze
moves and break them down and and what I
would do I'm just trying to transition
you into something else here randomly
but what I would do and why I was able
to put in so many hours I would analyze
the move okay I want to I want a second
deal a certain way so I'd analyze the
mood okay okay I want this I want that I
want no leaking and so I analyzed what I
want to do and I'd practice it in slow
motion till every exact lead element of
the muscle memory was firmly embedded in
my brain okay then I would turn it into
a subconscious habit we all have habits
forward tap you tap an right tapping our
feet that's idle energy wasted it's like
an engine of a car running going nowhere
just idling that's it's still energy
expelled right so what I did I turned I
learned to take all that energy and
funnel it into just my hands and what's
in my hands and so that's why I would
take it and that turned into
subconscious habit and that move I would
then Saturn
because it hundreds of times I do it
well at times tens of thousands of times
hundreds of thousands of times then
maybe two or three years late all the
time will go by golly I got it
and then and then some of the things
Vernon would say that's not possible to
do and and in and so I would figure it
out analyze it show it to him and then
well what I loved discovering in the
process of prepping for this
conversation and I want to put a button
in the black belt test of a second but
that Vernon would describe to you the
ideal of how something would be
performed even though in reality he
hadn't seen it executed that perfectly
and you with your powers of
visualization and the way that you would
digest his teaching would then go and
develop the ability to do what he
thought could not be done at least
that's that's my understanding that's
exactly right and and he did that
further I had the privilege of being
with Professor Vernon for 17 years in
those first five to six 10 years like
you said he would describe to me sit
Richard this is the way it has it has to
be done your hands have to be natural
you don't want this deep grip when
you're going to deal a second or a
bottom your fingers need to be on the
sides because it's more natural that's
more the way you're gonna see a jet your
your general person in the public hold
different cards and so you don't want to
create any unnatural suspicion by your
actions and so he would tell me oh okay
you have to be able to do with those
fingers on the side and so okay fingers
on the side and you don't want you don't
want any of this action here so I
practiced with my hand on the table
without moving it and so I would take
the pieces what he said and I faxed it
it would actually told me he said he'd
say feel my hands
feel the position my hands around I
would feel this hands okay god I got it
okay okay I got it so I'd see the
picture in my mind of what his hands
were showing me but he never did it
because it's an action I really couldn't
see him
the action because of my answer get in
the way of him executing the app but I
knew the action of what he was showing
so in my mind I would see his hands
visualize what he said this is the way
it should be done and then I would come
up with it and create it and then the
next time you see me he'd go watch this
function perfect touch it you didn't get
all excited you have all the other card
guys come over in their wife a perfect
weather perfect weather varies well my
critics at the time but we became a good
friend same with Tony Giorgio but so
that's what he would do is he tricked me
and it was only till years later that he
told me he made them up he just wanted
to see what this obsessed kid would come
up with isn't that's why it might work
is kind of as most but 99.9% of the
gamblers garden out there will tell you
it's it's unique and separate from the
way any other person handles the cards
and I want to type one one loose end
with the black belt test just to flash
forward because we covered a lot of it
but 10 fresh fighters 10 rounds you end
up with a broken arm but at some point
seventh row in the seventh round so
you're fighting with a broken arm
there's footage of this of course in the
documentary which I encourage everybody
to see and you get your black belt there
was coverage of this experience of
course there were there were some
cameras but also there's a piece in
wasn't the LA Times only time now why
did you my understanding is you did not
not like a p-series not like the
headline why is that well because they
used the word blind man earns black belt
and at that time I was very stubborn and
I was just stubborn and probably
self-absorbed and I wanted my work to
stand on its own and I wanted to earn it
the way Terry Cook John Douglas and the
other his top other black both fighters
do that's why when they offered me an
honorary black belt he says he said you
put in your time you put in your lumps I
said no I'm going to do it the way you
did and then that's what I started the
training
I described early but took me 10 years
and out of 13 years in three months and
five days from when I started when I
finally got it from beginning to super
nuts and um but anyway um the fact that
they had to put the word blind man earns
black belt and to me it was like yeah I
don't like the theme handicap makes good
I want the thing okay I just made good
because I did it and it didn't and to be
perfectly honest with you I kept telling
people I wanted to do it they way they
did it and people say but you didn't and
I go yes I did and it was literally Tim
within the last six months if someone
said something that I understood what
they said when they said I didn't do it
the way they did it I did it way the way
they couldn't have done it yeah they
weren't sight-impaired when they did it
I was I never understood what they were
saying because I'm so pay catted about I
wanted I wanted to do it the way they
did it but then when you flip it I I
finally got the message I did it in a
way that that they it was very unlikely
that they or anyone else would have had
a hard time doing if I could have done
it at all Oh probably next to impossible
if not possibly yeah and I want to dig
into the visualization because this
seems to be such a superpower and I
might ask you what you consider to be
your superpowers but this this this
visualization and the CBS and the
eidetic memory that you mentioned really
seem to coalesce to give you some
incredible abilities and whether that's
the feats of strength or work with the
cards I you mentioned earlier that the
way you see things when you're scanning
or planning the construction the design
and construction of three-story patio or
deck for instance is different from
dreaming and so that begets the question
what is dreaming like for you
ah very good very good question
recipe Oh like that like you were saying
I see my subconscious in external space
so you know and it's just a constant
stagnant situation of all these colors
patterns just there until I want to
bring them into play and it doesn't
matter if it's day night if my eyes are
open or closed I see the exact same
thing with my eyes covered up in a vault
I'll see these vivid bright colors when
there's absolutely no way of light
getting in mm-hmm
that when I dream in my dreams I'm never
sight-impaired and I see I dream in full
color with audio and visual and I see
perfectly and everybody I see in those
dreams is perfectly clear hmm which I
you know that that someone brought that
to my attention and some questions that
I was asked and and I thought but I
guess that's kind of unusual but yeah
I'm never like I said part of the dream
is never that I'm Harvard citing press
nor do I see any of the CBS the symptoms
in any my dreams now if I wake up in the
middle of night say and I had to take
some Tylenol or something from some
surgery I've had 24 surgeries from all
my high impact living and medication
when I wake up would turn everything
into a metallic colors and usually a lot
of times it's purple this is if you wake
up in the nola night middle the night on
after taking some kind of medication
from some kind of an injury that I'm on
medications turn it metallic and it
turns it usually a purple which is not
as not a pretty purple to me I don't
like it
you mentioned marine was one of your
favorite colors and in row blue on the
blue spectrum what other favorite colors
do you have and did you have them before
losing your sight or did you develop
them afterwards I probably wasn't aware
of favorite colors before right so much
as I am now because I see them all the
time and and the different shades
depending on the time of year
the particular day sometimes it's just
really vivid blues and I just it's just
beautiful sometimes when I'm out walking
with my beautiful wife Kim and my by CBS
will create a skyline okay in other
words the things will be darker here and
I feel like that's the skyline and then
it'd be lighter shades to give the image
of a you know sky okay and then and then
I go in and I have to ask my wife
this is still light out because it will
stay there and sometimes it's late
tonight and I can't get that the I can't
get it or sometimes it does can bother
me because I want that to go down
because it's now nighttime so there are
there are some times that it will be a
bit of a distracting side what I have as
a note to ask I didn't want to get any
of the details beforehand but and know
to ask you about your experience of wind
ah now so fine I can see the wind blow
whenever I'm walking down the street
with my with Kim or whatever if there I
will of course I automatically see the
images of trees but they're more like
clouds in there in there being green
shapes and colors to replicate and give
the image of trees okay but whenever the
wind blows everything all my all my
visualization things that I see we'll go
with that wind
they will gust if it gusts they'll move
a little bit more if I do this
everything just now just wet look it's
like out my tires I have dives I they
had do it everything just jerked over
and went back straight they're just
weird little things like when I go in
and I'm in a pool my eyes are closed the
whole time I know I don't need to need
my eyes open when I'm swimming there I'm
gonna worry about the chlorine and stuff
right and so when I'm above the pool
there there's a certain hue the level in
other words a level of brightness of the
color when I go under the water I
actually see myself going underwater and
the hue changes they it deepens like put
on
sunglasses are sunglasses off sim
glasses on and even as I made that image
my eyes are closed
I just offset things what darker and
lighter I can pretend that I'm opening
in close I open and close my eyes it
will the hue it's like pulling down a
shade that has a sunblock on our Sun but
because of sunglasses we need a best way
to describe you is what the hue changes
and then now if I just pretend that a
miserly old clothes the whole time
I'm pretending that opening and closing
my eyes it'll do the same thing and I'm
a relevance that had to anything but
it's just these little gates you know
this is just a conversation for your
friends nobody nobody listening or
watching and so I'm just following my
own interest and I want to talk about
the enjoyment of not relaxing that's
more said with a smile but when we took
a little break to have some water I you
said to me relaxing is not relaxing and
you talked about happy being told to
relax or ask to relax is like being
punished and put in the corner for
misbehaving at school for you in that
case given your obsessive compulsive
dedication to training to card mechanics
to movement how do you replenish what
what activities do you find recharge
your batteries and maybe you could just
elaborate on to me relaxing is not
relaxing okay yeah I'm going to bring up
a friend of mine who's like her
brother's name was Luke quorum mm-hmm he
was the director of the film dealt that
you mentioned and and I'll just say
something quick about the film if it
wasn't for Luke in particular part I'd
say 80% Luke and then Bradley and
Russell the producer and the writer but
Luke was the one that just had the
creativity if if I if they would've let
if they would listen to me and they
listened zero to me they did that I
would have screwed up the film
the brilliance of that film is I lit at
the feet of the director Luke and he
would tell me if he actually lived with
me he had his own place in my house when
at certain times Luke's room and I never
have my may attempt I didn't know the
cameras on or off and he would say well
let's chill yell and you know which I
found I was word for relaxing and chill
I don't want to what is this a pill on
and I said relaxing for me relaxing it's
not fun relaxing it's like when I was a
kid I was being punished and my parents
as a pleasure I'd have to stand in the
corner for an hour and just stare at the
corner to me chilling is not fun
chilling relaxing is not fun Jimmy
relaxing is adventure and that I would
tell people not tell Luke I'd say don't
worry about the end result when the film
is done it's gonna be a piece it'll be
what it is and it will be finished enjoy
the journey
okay and look at every obstacle and
every challenge in every hurt and pain
that you come across as part of the
adventure of the journey when you read a
book you don't want a book that oh he
went and he entered this arrest anyone
and then he entered that one no trouble
he won and he climbed this mountain
anyone that's the boy you have to have
antagonist protagonists and you have to
have challenges you have to have things
that you have to overcome so I would
tell people whatever the situation is
look at it as part of the adventure I am
my livelihood we almost came to an end
five years ago well multiple times like
I said I've had 24 surgeries I had to
recount them just last week going away
my 23 22 23 or 24 it roy's I've had I
have to steal knees from all the years
kagan I took a shot here roundhouse kick
here and there first I did surgery and
finally had to be replaced and just you
know millions of kicks just fine
gentlemen I've had five hernia surgeries
I've had I did a backflip off my front
porch landing on my fifth disc of my bed
I'm right back on the brick drove it out
my bellybutton I've had three back
surgeries and and then fortunately but
finally and they
and that's so complicated they just
doctors it's just they have a hard time
with Max and then I they have this thing
called a neurostimulator Medtronic makes
and I have that and that short-circuits
the pain from the back to your brain
amazing ever since that night my wife
said give our life back we have we have
this table available we have some cards
would you like to like to show anything
I do yeah you have a deck of cards you
after yourself right I do shuffle them
up all right we'll say this and how how
amateur the shuffle convey here yeah
usually I can barely shuffle two hands
well then use one yes I just showed yeah
okay all right we're good to go
switch decks with me all right okay you
know in poker you've heard of like what
wild cards like deuces are wild baseball
have multiple wild cards the other games
I'll just cut a card that would be the
wild card just cut off half the deck I'm
gonna move there's one card left over
here I mean I can put on my deck yes
we're not atheria okay just cut the deck
in half here tell me when you got it
okay just to make it more red just say
any random number three four or five
seven anything you want six six one two
three four five six
what's that card clan time so the
Queen's will be the wild card okay then
you just shuffle these cards right and
it now have you ever played poker for
money yeah and let me ask this have you
ever played in the casino or have you
ever wondered I mean I play in a casino
am I getting conned I have lost in a
casino okay so that that thought has
crossed your mind am i getting caught
yeah now I'm gonna show you you just
handed me a randomized deck and I'm
gonna do this in an interesting way and
the high state games they'll cut between
every shuffle because that buries the
top and bottom half of the deck
I'll give the deck a little riffle and
they will people like to cascade the
cards into them give a cut so I'm
telling you what I'm doing as I do it I
shuffle did everything look legit
look legit and not a movie saw was so
you're already in trouble now actually
not a move I saw was was honest not a
one I got a one now show you how fast I
could uncut that deck what's that card
that is the two clubs the two of clubs
so they'll pass the deck to the right to
be cut and now the deck is
longer cut so to be still on top watch
again I'll watch again I'm showing you
how fast I can cut the deck the deck is
no longer cut yeah that was about a half
a second yeah now you've heard of Texas
Hold'em I have him okay well would you
let hand if hold them and then hold them
they have what's called a cut card or a
burn card therefore the card the deck on
a face-up card now after the fact you
gonna tell me keep everything off the
table here give me a full table yeah all
right after the fat you tell me how many
people step up to my Hold'em table let's
bake your number five or six because we
don't have a lot of room 5 to 5 players
1 2 3 4 5 5 2 3 4 5 burn and we almost
called the flop and what are those 3
cards you got the King of Hearts the 2
of hearts and the queen of clubs
deuces are not well but we did something
the Queens was your card and if that
means there's a pair of kings on the
table where there's a burn and a turn
what's that card that's a overturn so
right now we have three kings because
the Queen is a wild card what's that
card
that's a client right now we have four
kings a scared of our burn card and
you're my partner sitting over here and
hand number five let's see what you have
in the pocket what's that that's a plan
what's that that's a hint so in the
poker you would have five of a kind five
kings or you'd have a royal flush
depending on how you wanted to play they
have in other words you killed yes
lauded them beat them with the big time
okay now we shuffle that deck okay I'll
do I'll show you how far I can push the
envelope all right so I'll shuffle this
one I think I think we got two cards I'm
gonna start it up on that one okay
that's your job make sure that one's all
legitimate yep
okay and then I'll switch with you there
we go okay and you can make sure
everything's legitimate at one yeah I
will give the deck a cut and we'll play
my favorite game seven card stud and
this would take a couple minutes to
unfold but it's interesting that we have
a deck of cards shuffled by till now we
would say with the same number of
players what I said you choose four
players or five you choose for where do
you want to sit number one number two
number three or number four I'll be
number one number one
oh shoot I'm getting ready I'm doing a
card in slow motion to hand number one
before I continue to take these deck
this deck mix them up don't give me the
whole deck back
just pour any random part of that deck
and put them in my hands just do
something quickly just a couple of turns
no more than a couple Bluff to get
around just a staff so I'm gonna work
with whatever you give me okay Tim just
having me back on random stack of cards
we're playing at dealing a card to plan
and number two player number three and
player number four your number one slow
motion watched carefully there's your
card and we go player two three four now
we have what I call the door car which
means the face-up cards what's that card
Jack of smash 1 player 2 player 3
therefore you're number one what's that
card ace of clubs two number three
number four you're number one what's
that card is of don't mix them up reach
them up becomes more mix up the entire
whatever you're the boss okay and just
have any part of that deck you want so
you do it everything you can to screw
things up okay and you just fell okay
that's like five cards less than the
last time you gotta me okay we have
player two player three player four and
so far we have three cards face up yes
sir
and what's that card it's a queen of
diamonds wild card what did it do it
again mix them up have me any part of
the deck you want so you shuffle e
cutting you choose how you chose how
many players you chose where you want to
sit you having me any random part of the
deck oh my gosh
getting stingy down to six cards player
two player three player four and we
always called down-and-dirty I'm now
dealing the card off the top to Tim's
first position two three four put that
with the rest of the stack okay now
let's see what you have in your hand
with them seven card stud
hi sugar go that means high Spade in the
hole splits the money so let's see what
you have what's that card clean and dyes
are clean a wild card so we'll put it
over here and what's that ace of done
that would be a pair of aces here the
Queen's wild with that ace cloves now
equals three aces what's that this is
jack of spades act what's that that's a
ten of Spades ten ten jack ace what's
that that's the
Queen of Spades another wild card so
right now you have four to a tsa's and
two queens right that's right
so you right now input with you that
would equal four aces and the best
possible hand in wild card is five aces
we're playing high Spade in the hole
splits apart with that yes
ace of aces pastes five aces the best
possible hand you can get in poker
there's five aces you shuffled you cut
you chose how many players you wanted
you chose where you wanted to sit and
you met kept mixing them up and you
didn't even give me a project you can
honestly say that Turner doesn't play
with a full bag yes I dealt you the
perfect can in poker
that's regrettable it's incredible house
matter yeah yeah that's incredible
amazing all right but that shows you how
far I can push and that particular thing
to be and I know this and I don't mean
to sound boastful cuz it's hard to talk
about when you're asking people asking
questions about yourself it's hard to
talk about yourself and not sound bad
but Vernon when he first saw me do that
I said what do you think about to mine
this and this and this
and you write your parrot gosh nah not
possible I can't be done yeah nice oh
you said you said you can't do it
because three reasons one your brain
cameras move respond that fast your
hands cannot be that sensitive and you
would break rhythm with those who put
those all cards back together from this
deck okay he said that's not possible
and I were at the Magic Castle and for
10 minutes i sat there but he was
sitting if the bar and I was standing
next to him and I was depressed for 10
minutes I said they're gone
this is the ultimate this is the perfect
way this is the and I thought it he said
it can't be done then I'll said never
remembered but I can't do it I said
professor come watch my show and he came
out of the shell after we go Roger what
the hell were your daughter now I don't
understand what the hell you were doing
I said remember when you said you can't
combine this in this that's what I'm
doing
and it goes back come in watch her watch
- and everybody for the next 18 months
every time I was there you'd have me
sell for the cards how many pairs you
want where do you once sit watch us
watching the Oh
at two years there you go understand it
he knows exactly what I'm doing and
exactly how I'm doing it yeah that's
amazing
I so I have these all the cards face in
the same way there I I guess two decks
worth of cards I don't know how they're
split up fifty to fifty joules to say
great you know who knows how many
roughly roughly fifty to another I
suppose
wonderful so you now you just just
because this is mentioned before we
start recording you audit cards is that
right what I'm that or you how was my
turn analyze yeah us playing card
company is the largest maker of cards in
the United States
mm-hm and they just merged with Carter
Monday which is the biggest card maker
they've been started making cards
eighteen 1765 and us playing card
companies and said eighty they've been
around for for 150 years and bicycle is
the most recognized packet cards in the
world it has been for over 100 years and
in 1998 1988 I got some cards they were
so bad I told them these are not the
cards you been making I can prove prove
that you are subcontracting your paper
out blah blah blah anyway they sent a
rep I proved who I was and they said he
was been proven right then in 1993 they
started miss cutting their cards by
turning the things over I said these are
not the cards you've been making for a
hundred years I can prove it and at that
time they were getting flack from the
casinos with a car the seals were not
not happy with the cards there was
something wrong with them and I'm the
one that identified the problem and and
that was the blade was going through the
wrong side of the card which affected
the integrity of the card in them the
ability for it to properly be
properly and so then they finally put me
on retainer in the 1990s and they I
helped them make the best card in the
world and they do make the best cards in
the world and and just give you an idea
how far there a director of research and
development would push me he would send
me out okay usually it was tea dozen
decks or like 20 decks but I'll make it
real small so you guys that let us say
six decks
yeah so there's
if there's two doesn't be there would be
12 pairs okay 12 pairs so we were small
reduce our illustration to down a 6-bit
six steps there's three pairs and one of
the - 3 pairs index through three three
pairs yeah six cards six decks which is
three pairs okay so we're down to six
decks which would be three pairs and
then why say pairs each each pair was
ran together that was a particular run
of that deck okay
okay and so they would they would say
one of the decks they just changed one
of the chemicals in the Cody this is
probably though the most elaborate one
that I did just one of the chemicals was
changed that's all chemical not the
whole process when the chemicals was
changed in their coating and so not only
did I have to say
deck one in three or match two and
formats and five and six or a match and
it was five and six that had the
chemical change and so not only did I
and and they had those cards coded when
I say coated Eric a secret code like q7
5 to 9 1 6 J which that was their key in
Cincinnati to understand these two of
the pair these two of the pair of these
2 the bear I did not have a key right
you know but I just had these random
numbers that I got put down in my report
my son Jason would tell me well this one
dad is j75 - this one is 6 7 j 4 and
which meant absolutely nothing to me and
i find out to c7 j 4 and they you would
they were the matches so I'd have to
impair them match them up and then
analyze with a snap the embossing depth
that caught the caliper why I call the
right period and all these things and
which one is a better card and help then
they would take that information and
fine tune their machines to help you
make the cards that that that they make
which are by far the finest card you can
buy there are no one yes so I know we
have just a little bit of time left and
we're practically neighbors
I'm very very close by I'm curious to
know then this this this is sometimes a
difficult question but I'll just ask one
or two more questions if you could put a
message or quote anything non-commercial
on a billboard to get a message out to
millions or billions of people is there
anything that comes to mind that you
might put on that billboard yeah
in the unite and America we have
opportunities success depends upon the
use we make of those opportunities
mmm that would be one the other word
would be not going down not going down
not going down another one would be
consider every obstacle as I measure
every obstacle challenge hurt pain in
your life as part of the adventure of
life that's what give light gives life
spice you know we know and then circling
back to when that was talking about the
surgeries and how my career was almost
at an end I was at Penn & Teller's
theater I was gonna be on their show
their fourth season and a third season
and I was in the gym the real gym where
else with my friend Doug Gorman and I
said okay I paid $17 for my workout
that's a ridiculous workout part and so
I was I as soon as I got in there when
those benches that you set up like this
to like you're doing standing curls yo
you sit new curls or you can recline it
back for like trio triceps or lay it all
the way back here on do sit-ups on there
just double punch the decimal bench and
it was propped like this at about 40
yeah at 45 degree and I couldn't that
hold that that I couldn't get it to go
down and I felt up it was butted up
against the wall and so I took that
bench and I moved it over like this and
WHAM my thumb was here and it was a
commercial-grade
been shot the steel bars that when we
run around here and the steel bars that
that was the frame of the vents just
and crushed my thumb what did I do
yeah I know he's crazy and your people
that are listening watching say yeah
he's a little on the crazy side and oh
okay don't let me get off-track on here
but did you know I'm a sir I'm a
certified oddball certified I'm
certified my dad did see your card yeah
explain
you've heard of Ripley's Believe It or
Not right yes in 1980 for us on the TV
series replaceable you're not hosted by
Jack Palance I'm also an exhibit the
second largest Ripley's in the country
and I'm in the 2015 issue of Ripley's
Believe it or not book of I pop and
oddities right supersede associate
stated like I have a certified quantity
so you might be an oddball Tim I'm sorry
you're certified I'm a certified I guess
is uh so this contraption can describe
like them and I called Doug I said bring
me a bucket of ice and don't ask any
questions and I figure I save $17 for
this workout I'm not gonna select price
for three minutes worked out for three
minutes
ice 15 minutes worked out for serious
face where I worked out oh my gosh my
thumb was as big as my big toe I go I
ran upstairs grab my cards and went oh
my gosh I can't feel so I called the
producers Lincoln and Lincoln and Andrew
they were the executive producer so I
said Linc
um I have a little trouble um a bench
crushed my thumb I think I could do the
first and third part of what we were but
I don't think I do the second
get down here he says you're going to
her emergency room they sent me to the
emergency room and they got in there and
the first thing they did is they poked a
hole and they said a fountain of blood
shot out I ended up having to go into
surgery and you can and because that I
thought this may be the end of my career
and Luke and the boys were flying in to
get some footage with then and teller
for delt and they were in air when this
happened so they landing and they're
coming into 5 pennants film Penn &
Teller and about you know whatever they
were gonna ask them only to find out
that I just got crushed and oh then
instead they're filming me showing my
thumb that's every shade of black and
blue but the color is supposed to be
anyway so I ended up
in surgery and I thought okay if this is
the end of my life I don't want to be I
told the surgeon do not I don't want to
be out not want to be I want fully
conscious I've went through multiple
surgeries and I'll just shuffle the
cards with my other hand while you work
on this one and that'll just that'll
that'll be my anesthetic and so he
thought I was nuts and you can watch it
it's a and I said I want to film that
tip so if this isn't in my career I
wanted footage and so they said okay
well you just put on sees the other side
of the business he can film it and then
you can go on your tumors crush the
allene film feature and crush stealing
thumb when is the short version ones
long but long religious it's on YouTube
crush stealing thumb was somebody you'd
look it up but after once it's graphic
because he he takes us believe takes a
spoon and pops my thumb open like a hood
of a car or then he takes it he cuts it
open and he squeezed the button we're
talking the whole time back and forth
and I'm shuffling cards they they would
go back for it shuffling in the thumb
and and we're time all this and and I
said man this is so cool and he goes why
don't people want to do this he says
they go schizoid he because she gets a
phrenic when they see just says go
through something like this and said I
have to be totally unconscious before I
did it I just had a hangnail rubriz this
and doctor anyway but but I that that
gets back to yeah I am a certified lot
more so you see how your son popped open
like the hood of the car and well we'll
link to those videos and the show notes
I teamed up blog so people be able to
find all of those videos and what
happened after that do you mean a Penn &
Teller no yeah Lincoln Henry and you
said you'll come back from our fourth
season don't worry about it right now
take care of your stomach it literally
took to the day before my thumbnail came
back because they didn't know if it was
gonna take where I go and do a grad
another one where I was gonna end up
with no family at all unfortunately I
grew out a new one and it was literally
Friday before that my manicures finally
got the last part of them were Wiggly
Wagle
looking thumbnail to be matched up and I
went on I started the filming on the
following Monday so it took almost that
year to the day and and so I got on the
show and had a blasters and I fooled
them faster than anybody in the history
of their show because you know they and
it was really fun their night and Penn &
Teller just amazing performers they are
just tire arts animals and in Penn &
Teller is so funny and people don't
realize it and if you watch on the show
and I didn't told this afterwards he was
staring staring at what I'm doing in the
in he's trying to say go bring down the
trophy now and over the headpiece they
don't mean that generally we want you to
do his entire act and then and then
beforehand they said Ritchie you can't
tell us how you do this so we can make a
judgement this is their judges Johnny
Thompson and Michael close I said what
you know Devon and I are the only ones
that really knows their stuff we know
that we got to make some judgment I said
okay boys I showed them in slow motion
what I was doing I showed and they
killed my god it really is impossible
and so then what Pena's over his head
this is what I was told is don't stir it
up they were supposed to times four
seven six minute interview with Alison
while they discussed how to do it then
of course they headed down to one minute
when it broadcasts and they go they said
over the head but don't ask us we don't
know Ali did it and so then Penn turns
around and says we have nothing to say
you fooled us and then but the cool part
was I walked offstage with Pam and I
hear this and this is exactly how I talk
Richard FFF I said who's that it's me
teller he said it was so wonderful to be
so completely and thoroughly astonished
I've never seen anything like that in my
life
they said let's get some selfies and
then the really fun thing was at
midnight I day I get a call they tell it
they said tell it once enough we can
come up get outside deck of cards from
you I said this is backwards I'm
supposed to ask enough for autographs
from them and I said just pen what what
do they so would you Ken would love it
anyway so that was kind of a really cool
thing and like I said they're
extraordinary extraordinarily talented
and extraordinary
and I was so honored at that they like
dealt and then they tell her I actually
wrote one of the on the film posters we
all know the blazes yeah very well yeah
and the entire story I mean this is this
is a perfect way to wrap up because that
entire story makes me think back to Tony
Giorgio early on and what was what was
he saying don't make the money everybody
won't get the money now later though
later though to any what did he say in
2001 I just finished my show at the
castle and there's Tony and he and I
battled each other for 20 years 25 years
and they said Richard Tony's here to see
you and there was a what's called the
Vernon seats were Vernon had won Gordon
that's where Tony was seed because Verde
had passed away nine years ten years
before and and they had one seat across
waiting for me to sit down all these top
card guys are standing there waiting
they want another battle between Georgia
and Tony and Giorgio and Turner Giorgio
in turn they know they always have these
showdowns like gunfighters and so I
didn't want to have any part of it and I
said now understand they for an hour
they said they finally said Richard Tony
was waiting then finally I thought to
myself you know what Tony was mean and
hard on me but I have to credit at least
half of my accomplishments to him being
my antagonist and I thought and I
thought okay and I said Tony I just want
to thank you for all your years of
encouragement you were hard on me you're
a divisive at times but people respect
you because you knew the real work and
you could do the real work and because
you pushed me hard you made me better
and I wanted to thank you for that he
goes why thank you Richard that's very
nice of you did you ever get that Center
deal down and and of course he knew I
did I said would you mind showing us so
now I sit out now for the next two and a
half hours we're doing what everybody
wants in after every thing you turn
drives I don't get the money that'll get
the money and then he actually wanted to
he actually proposed he said we have the
perfect
gamm the perfect threesome he said I'll
tell the people your high-stake gambler
and but you can't see but you would love
to play Hold'em I'll be the person to
tell reads the cards to you
he said there's not five people in the
in the gaming world that understands
your work he said you we have a third
agent third part of the crew that you'll
deal the good hands to and so from the
guy who said never get the money
actually propose let's put them together
as a team and and hustling together
and and then I actually have a
handwritten letter five page handwritten
letters one of my best treasures from
Tony Giorgio and and then emails that
say love Tony oh yeah is it so I'm went
from won't get the money to just talking
nasty and mean and times that the
council you did have to be taken up
taken out of the castle in ways he did
wasn't pleasant to him to to become a
very dear friend and I actually had the
privilege of writing one for one of the
magazine says obituary because I have
thirty nine related year relationship
with him from from fighting to to
earning his respect and really quickly
that came from my first director a man
named Steve Terrell who was a TV and
movie star back in the 50s and early 60s
and he was I was the theater company
called the Lambs players from 1972 to 78
and one of the things he would tell me
is he would well on stage he had watched
me and I'll be looking out the corner of
my eye when we talked about that is that
new forward vision so I'm talking to my
character and I'm looking over here he
said Richard you need to it looks odd
for you looking off his side I know that
you can't see the where the shadow is if
unless you turn your head to the side he
said just look at the voice and he
taught me how to square my head towards
the voice and give the impression that I
could see them he said you've seen that
actor will play the part of his that
blind person you flipped the rules
you're a blind potent person
you played the part of an of a sighted
person and and he said in a few he says
he was watching me practicing before and
after every scene he says you love cars
if you become the best card man in the
world
you will earn the respect of your worst
enemies
and then that was the case with Tony
Giorgio he was the guy who was an enemy
he was my they were it was my nightmare
every time I went to the castle if we
went into each other to become it a very
dear man and I mean that's that sounds
like a another billboard so if I could
put if I could put up a billboard for
you that's what it would say that'll get
the money get the money and this has
been so fun we didn't even get into your
hustling stories and this this entire
prep has been an embarrassment of riches
so I hope this isn't the last time that
I see you hopefully we get to spend some
more time together you name it well if
I'm up here I'll let you know I'm coming
anytime you want to visit or do
something again I'm at your I might be
my honor honor and privilege to hang out
it together even if it's to go have a
protein shake protein shake or maybe I
can just get my ass handed to me in the
gym or but or maybe maybe a bit of both
and what a pleasure to spend time with
you finally in person which I've wanted
for so long and people can find out all
about you Richard Turner 52 the no
defense to Richard Turner 52 calm on
social and I'll link to all of these in
the show notes as well youtube.com
forward slash ace 52 that's a sa t 52
and then also youtube.com forward slash
Richard Turner 52 will link to all of
this for speaking your repped by APB
speaking Vera American program bureau
APB and that's one of my favorite things
to do now is for some reason people are
inspired and my wife says people want to
hear your story and they always want to
just be an entertainer but I have to say
I I'm really blessed that I have the
privilege of speaking and entertaining
some of the most amazing companies in
the on the planet and I can't wait to
see what you do next I you are also of
course featured in delt which has at
least last I checked a 95 percent on
Rotten Tomatoes and
it is one of my favorite documentaries
I've seen and certainly last five years
it's it's just spectacular and I am
greatly inspired by you slightly
terrified of you and I look forward to
to watching your further ongoing
adventures and hope to hope to have a
protein shake in the near future but
thanks very much for coming really
appreciate it was my pleasure Tim it was
a pleasure being with you and I'm
honored as well thank you sir and for
everybody watching or listening we will
have a lot to link to in the show notes
and many resources we also have of
course the video if you're listening via
audio which you can check out at
youtube-dot-com forward-slash tim
ferriss or just go to tim not blog and
you'll find it there and for the show
notes all the links just got a tuned up
log forward slash podcast type in
Richard Turner and bam lickety-split
you'll have what you need and until next
time be safe train hard practice
perfectly if you're going to practice
and thanks for listening thanks for
watching
you